[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale ryder cup au programme
aujourd'hui pour ce jour numéro 2 nous
partirons du côté du village de la ryder
cup qui vend tous les produits dérivés
de la compétition nous évoquerons
également la ryder cup junior avec un
match amical qui est organisé
aujourd'hui et bien sûr derrière moi
l'entraînement un des joueurs
[Musique]
et parmi elle est partie d'entraînement
les plus suivies il y avait évidemment
celle de tiger woods nous avons
rencontré quelques supporters surexcités
pour moi c'est incroyable de voir e
tiger route beaucoup une fille hyper
content sinon peu une résurrection d'un
joueur qui était tombé très très très
bas et qui a été remontée qui a monté
avec beaucoup de volonté du plaisir
pourquoi bas parce que je suis
impressionné shi
impressionnés pages qui joue bien
pendant des greens ce mercredi les
organisateurs en ont également profité
pour peaufiner les derniers détails de
la cérémonie d'ouverture
les 24 joueurs et leur capitaine
prendront place sur la scène et comme
présentateurs on retrouvera l'ancien
footballeur et maintenant animateur de
télévision david ginola
je suis très fier honorée et très fière
des gens tant que français d'être là
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui va être diffusé une manifestation
qui va être diffusé dans le monde entier
donc en tant que français mais je suis
fier d'être sur console et de
représenter à mon petit niveau la france
nous allons faire à présent à les
magasins direction la boutique
officielle de cette ryder cup 2018
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans un véritable temple
de la consommation à tous les clients
venus du monde entier peuvent acheter à
des tasses des ti peuvent h également
des clubs de golf ou des polos et
justement ils viennent du monde entier
et nous sommes avec brad qui nous vient
de houston dans le texas brad what have
you got a new bag
qu'est ce que vous avez dans votre sac
et à agatha j'ai un polo pour monfils
il a 11 ans et c'est un grand fan de la
ryder cup
j'ai la baisse de l'équipe américaine
parce qu'il fait un peu froid dehors il
ça permet de garder la chaleur et j'ai
une boîte de balles de golf
professionnel que je vais ramener à mon
ami à houston it's important for you to
have got something about the ryder cup
c'est important pour vous d'avoir ce tas
de choses pour la ryder cup 2018
absolument c'est vraiment génial d'être
ici à la ryder cup et je voulais avoir
des choses à ramener à la maison pour
pouvoir m'en souvenir good shoping voilà
brad va continuer son shopping et moi je
vais peut-être me laisser tenter
également
bon
alors là on en a pour 50 euros
alors on est quand même très loin des
5100 12 euros dépensés par un américain
irs ce deuxième jour de ryder cup
c'était aussi l'occasion pour 192
enfants de saint quentin en yvelines de
découvrir à la ryder cup 2018 après une
matinée à bien chargé nous les avons
rencontrés juste à l'heure du déjeuner
moi j'ai adoré ce moment parce qu'on
partage des moments entre gros peintre
ami et c'est quand même incroyable de
participer à la ryder cup parce que
c'est un événement international voilà
je pense qu'on aura donné le maximum
d'explications je sais pas si nous
retiendrons tout mais je pense que quand
même ça reviendra ray pour eux je pense
que c'est une excellente expérience pour
clôturer ce mercredi 26 septembre à la
ryder cup junior s'exporte de disneyland
paris jusqu ici au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
cette compétition amicale oppose les
meilleurs jeunes joueurs américains aux
meilleurs jeunes joueurs européens on
écoute les réactions nous sommes très
enthousiastes
on est très heureux d'être ici avec
tiger avec tous les européens est juste
allé l'europe et profitons de cette
ryder cup
ce sont les pépites parce qu'à travers
le mode de sélection ce sont vraiment
les meilleurs espoirs de la planète la
planète du golfe et la plupart d'entre
eux après avoir joué la junior ryder cup
en général intègre quelques années plus
tard la grande ryder cup
l'image du jour elle concerne l'espagnol
john rabe de la team europe il a reçu
juste avant la conférence de presse ce
matin la visite de ses grands-parents et
l'émotion était au rendez-vous - cas
beaucoup tellement d'émotion dans la moi
qui suis très contente
il est très sérieux très travailleur et
très gentil et - karine gauche et moi
c'est le meilleur de la famille c'est
terminé pour cette émission spéciale
ryder cup rendez vous demain pour de
nouvelles aventures golfique
[Musique]